- I'm never on defense.
I'll bail, I'll bail.
When I when I was dating,
if I saw anything
that wasn't in,
if I dated,
so I hate negativity.
It's why we
have a great culture.
If I dated a girl that
I realized very
quickly like she liked,
it was intriguing
to have conflict,
I literally bailed
immediately.
Out forever.
I have no effort
for defense.
I'm trying to win
every game 477 to 433
and I'm talking about baseball.
You know what I mean?
- [Man] I don't watch
baseball but yeah.
- But you know what I mean?
- [Man] Yeah.
But baseball where
there's lower scoring.
That's why that's the analogy.
Fucking soccer.
I'm trying to score
so many points
that I'm not worried
about the casualties.
You know this more because
you've been at Vayner
like I never care about
the failures at Vayner.
I love when people
come in to me and be like,
"Listen, I've got to talk
to you about this problem.
"It's really gonna
undermine us."
I'm like, "Are you
a fucking idiot?
"How the fuck you
think we got here?"
If you want me to
play your micro game,
I'm gonna look
like everybody else so
I'm always on the offense,
always macro and
always very aware
of what I want to happen.